let's go to lj from las vegas
lj you are on the air morning david can
you hear me
i can hear you fine sir sir how are you
doing
good i'm going to call in a couple times
so um just
want to give you a call back and i saw
your video on youtube so i just wanted
to see if i
could get in thank you well we are here
we are here
i just wanted something to kind of give
a comment to the last discussion you had
um there's also another part of
conspiracy theories that we should also
be
uh you know be aware of okay is never
have a conversation with
uh about fire safety with an arsonist so
also depends on
necessarily who's having the discussion
that where you would basically have
those discussions on conspiracy theories
that's a very good point yeah and maybe
to like go with the covid lag
lap leak stuff or whatever like there's
a big contingent
that is pro-trump who feel
that if covid was a bio weapon created
in china
that it would then excuse trump's total
mishandling of the virus like they have
a political motivation now
i simply disagree that it would no
matter where covet came from trump
mishandled it
but they have a very particular interest
in pushing one narrative
and so i think you're absolutely right
that we should we should consider the
motivations of people pushing certain
ideas
absolutely um actually i'm um to discuss
trump a little bit i do
feel that in the media right now at the
moment there seems to be some kind of
fanaticism with discussing everything
that he does even though he's been
removed from facebook he's been removed
from twitter
um you know however short term those
removals are
there seems to be like almost this dream
that he comes back so that way they can
receive some more you know ratings and
some more
high review you know like more watch
time from uh the audiences out there
because
he was so good for them yeah i mean i'd
have
i'd want to hear more about who you
think is hoping trump comes back
i actually am really worried that he
comes back earlier this week i did a
segment explaining
i think that if there's a rematch of
2020 and 24
that it's very bad for joe biden i i
have a really hard time believing that
joe biden's going to do well in a
rematch against trump in 2024
for reasons i laid out if joe biden says
i'm not running and it's kind of handed
to kamala
i think that that would be really tough
if if trump runs so i'm actually i'm
hoping the opposite
you know i've said before in terms of my
level of coverage this guy
has done things that arguably should
should have gotten him arrested at
minimum and
he has lost almost no support from the
republican party that's really scary
that's
that's a problem with american culture
right now and so i'm covering
him to the extent that i do because he's
relevant
and he may be the king maker in 22 and
he may run in 24 and if he
runs i think it's conceivable that he
will win but in terms of ratings i mean
i'm more concerned with like what's good
for the country and trump coming back
would be very bad for the country so i
don't want it oh absolutely i completely
agree it just
it seems like and you know it fox news
already covers them all the time
right that's not the issue i'm talking
about it's just i feel like
when he puts out one of his long-form
tweets the the presidential releases
whatever they're called right yep yep
it's there's a romanticism that people
say it's like oh can you believe he's
still saying this i'm like yes
he said it for four years we already
know that yeah
i agree with you yeah yeah and with
those statements i mean we
we've basically started ignoring them
when they're relevant to something
happening bigger picture in the news
you know we'll include it as part of a
commentary but yeah i mean i think that
there's some channels where like
every day he's putting one out and
they're reading it and then doing
interviews on its basis that seems to me
like
maybe a little bit a little bit over the
line
absolutely so that's all i just want to
comment on i love the show
uh have a great day all right thank you
very much yeah good
okay